Il y avait une sorte de symbiose entre la vie et l'art.
Je crois que ce n'est pas fortuit
si zootrope se traduit par « la roue de la vie. »
(Musique)
Le film et la vidéo écrase la sculpture.
J'ai donc essayé d'imaginer
un manière de pouvoir visualiser la sculpture animée telle quelle,
tout en offrant une immersion totale dans l'animation.
C'est ainsi que m'est venue l'idée du zootrope en tunnel.
On marche avec une lumière stroboscopique à la main.
Là ou on dirige la lumière,
l'animation prend vie.
J'envisage de terminer ce projet d'ici 30 ou 40 ans.
(Rires)
J'ai déjà construit un prototype qui a la moitié de la taille réelle.
Il est recouvert de Velcro.
J'ai pu me coucher à l'intérieur sur ce plancher
et coller des séquences animées sur les parois
pour tester l'idée.
Les gens me disaient que ça ressemblait à un scanner IRM.
La connection médicale m'a marqué
car quand j'avais 14 ans,
on a diagnostiqué une dégénérescence de la rétine
qui érodait ma vue petit à petit.
Je n'avais jamais abordé ce sujet dans mon travail.
C'est ce que j'ai fait dans cette œuvre appelée « greffe. »
C'est un équipement médical imaginaire à grande échelle,
qui entoure le nerf optique.
Le public est, dans un certain sens, miniaturisé pour le découvrir.
Muni d'une lampe stroboscopique,
ils explorent la sculpture,
et découvrent des milliers de robots de la taille d'une cellule,
qui sont au travail, s'insérant et sortant du nerf optique,
déployés sur la rétine
pour la régénérer.
C'est le traitement de science-fiction que j'ai créé pour ma maladie incurable.
(Vrombissement des moteurs)
Dans le vrai monde de la recherche et de la thérapie génétique,
des gènes sains sont administrés à des cellules malades à l'aide de virus.
Voici l'expression de mon espoir coloré et soyeux.
Mais il y a également l'idée angoissante et glauque
que les virus se transforment en parasite envahissant notre corps.
La perte de ma vue m'a conduit à m'éloigner
des objets qui me déconnectent du monde.
Au lieu de me cloîtrer dans ma voiture,
je roule en vélo,
je prends les bus et les trains,
et je marche beaucoup.
Au lieu de travailler dans un studio, concentré sur un processus visuel intense,
je vais régulièrement à l'extérieur,
et je mets à contribution tous les sens.
Ce site est localisé à quelques heures à l'Est de San Diego, en Californie.
Mon frère vit là.
On est parti camper pendant quatre jours.
J'ai pris ma caméra,
et je me suis promené dans les canyons.
J'ai essayé d'imaginer et visualiser
quel genre de mouvement pourrait exister
dans cet endroit si statique et sans mouvement.
Je ne suis jamais allé dans un endroit plus figé.
J'ai compris que c'est le mouvement de mon corps dans le paysage
qui créait l'animation.
Le mouvement du changement de perspective.
J'ai donc créé l'œuvre « Grottes de boue » au départ de ces photos.
Il s'agit d'une superposition d'éléments imprimés.
C'est comme un zootrope mis à plat.
C'est mon interprétation d'une vue panoramique de l'Ouest.
A côté de l'élément imprimé, il y a un vidéo
qui dévoile l'animation qui se cache dans l'œuvre.
La partie la plus belle du projet
fut pour moi de passer du temps avec mon frère.
Il habite à 4 000 km de moi.
On restait simplement assis dans ce paysage éternel,
sculpté par l'eau pendant des millions d'années,
et on discutait.
On parlait de nos enfants qui grandissent,
de nos parents, au rythme plus lent,
de notre père, qui souffre de leucémie, de pertes de mémoires et d'infections.
Je me suis aperçu que nous, en tant qu'individu,
nous avons une fin,
mais en tant que famille,
nous faisons partie d'un cycle,
une espèce de roue de la vie.
Je vais vous laisser avec un hommage à un de mes mentors.
Elle me rappelle que la présence physique est cruciale
et que le jeu n'est pas un luxe,
mais une nécessité.
Elle s'appelle Pixie,
c'est notre chien.
Elle adore sauter.
(Aboiements)
(Aboiements et bruits de ressort)
Voici la nouvelle forme de zootrope
que j'ai développé au Centre de recherche de l'Image
à l'Université du Maryland, à Baltimore.
Ça s'appelle : « Zootrope en temps réel. »
(Aboiements)
(Aboiements et bruits de ressort)
Merci.
(Applaudissements)